you know when you auditioned and we can
keep all this when you auditioned for
that fabulous director did you did you
meet in person or was it um on the uh I
have a great audition story from it so I
had I had done two self tapes for it and
then they said okay come on and and in
and and do it for him for Chris Nolan
face to
face and
um I had met
Chris a
good 16 years prior he was scouting for
like the Dark Knight maybe or yeah I'm
not sure or or yeah maybe the Dark
Knight
and he was scouting at uh Hollywood uh
Los Angeles center studios which is
where we shot numbers and we were the
only show it was us and madmen so it's
this huge lot
downtown in the middle of downtown that
no one really uses much except for like
music videos come in for like two days
or you know some commercial some big
commercial like LeBron James will come
in for two days they need a Sound Stage
so they go for it there's all these
sound stages and um and mad men would be
there for like three months but we were
there for like 10 months out of the year
and all these movies would shoot there
for a day you know they' shoot they
literally you've seen it in half the
movies you've seen this sort of building
that they use that that's there that
used to be the old like 76 Union SoCal
Gas building anyway he was there and uh
and I was like oh [__] there's Chris
Nolan and he came up to me and he said
hey I think you're great on that show
this was numbers and I was like
whoa crazy and then you'd think you know
the thing is your worst mind goes to oh
well he's there you know that person
forgot about me or that person enjoyed
that thing that I was in but has no
interest in ever working with me but
that was very nice to hear that and so
knowing I was going in for him face to
face was not so intimidating I was like
oh I know that this guy enjoyed my work
at one point and so that wasn't
intimidating what was intimidating was I
showed up and they were like you're the
only one here for this oh which is like
oh it's yours to lose thing and I'm sure
you've been in that situation I'd rather
go against people than be alone me too
and and I thought I was showing up and
you know I also like need the motivation
like I walk in and there's another actor
there I'm like I I got it's like all of
a sudden I this is not when I work with
people but when I audition against
people I'm like oh I gotta I'm in a
championship fight and I got to knock
this guy out Y what can I like I know I
feel like I know what he's going to do
so I got to do something different so
going in alone was a little scary um
because then you go holy moly like they
really I'm this is it's it's mine to
lose and I went in and he gave me I had
two scenes I hadn't there was no script
available and I assumed that those two
scenes were the whole part you know
because you don't assume you've been
given anything more than that anyway so
I did the two scenes and he had me do it
three times and I try to switch it up a
little each time and after the third
time he said I want you to do it again
but this time I want you to do it like
you're driving home from this audition
and thinking I should have done it that
way
wow wow and luckily and I came to know
Chris is a very sarcastic and very funny
person right and but in the moment I
don't know that and luckily I played it
off you know I I actually laughed I
didn't get nervous I kind of went that's
funny and then I thought and then I even
said like
but my my drive home I'm going to do it
in the elevator um did the thing left
and was convinced I had ruined it like
totally convinced I'd ruined it and
you're driving home on your way back
from the audition I supposed to drive
home I was actually I was in LA and I
was supposed to drive back to my hotel I
drove straight to a
brewery and just downed a bunch of beer
just by myself
in at on like a Tuesday on at 2:00 it's
just literally me at the brewery just
getting just drowning my sorrows and
going holy [__] I had one of the biggest
opportunities I've ever had and I blew
it and um I was about like three or four
beers in pretty
rocked uh and the plan was to just you
know then sober up and drive home and
just spend the whole day at the
brewery and uh my agent called and said
you got
it the same day and I was
plastered in the parking lot of this
Brewery I
like needless to say I'm now 14 months
clean and sober I don't do that anymore
nice yeah why not
good thanks man but uh but yeah like uh
wa what so you you didn't know you
thought you had a couple scenes in this
movie and what's funny is I see you in
the movie and I'm like oh cool he's in
this he's got something and you the
integral part of the movie so then I
went and read the script the next day I
got called in and then he they said
we're going to let you read the
script uh in the office and then we're
going to take it back from you I was
like okay and the script was P printed
on dark red paper so you can't copy it
or read
it hard to read it was that secretive
and I'm reading it I'm like [__] man
there I am again and whoa [__] and it
came it dawned on me like he Chris
really believed in me you know you as an
actor you spend so much time going you
know I don't know who believes in me and
if they do I wish they would just show
up right now you know I know and then it
happens and that um it made me super
emotional you know he showed up after I
read it he wanted to talk to me about it
and I was just I had a [__] EA on my
face you know I was just like and I just
kept saying thank you I just kept saying
like thank thank you thank you wow
thanks and the coolest thing is like as
they were promoting the movie these last
few
months I had a little secret which was
that I wasn't just in it I was in it a
good deal